this week conflicts owners in New York
just days after Donald Trump was elected
president in one of the biggest
political upsets this country has seen
in decades and if the campaign rhetoric
is anything to go by those upsets are
just beginning my guest is David
Petraeus former US commander in Iraq and
former director of the CIA where does
America go from here
Dave Petraeus welcome to conflict zone
good to be with you Tim thanks you said
the day after the election of Donald
Trump that you gave him credit for
saying he tried to bind the wounds of
division and be the president for all
Americans which is what they all say I
guess how is anybody supposed to ever
believe a word Donald Trump says after
the kind of campaign we've seen well you
don't have to believe everything you
just have to see what's going to happen
I think that's really the question
anyway you know we look with every
presidential candidate there's always
that moment when presidential campaign
rhetoric has to turn into presidential
policy and that's I think what we're all
waiting to see this is a campaign that
ran old lies didn't it they ran on quite
significant lies in particular the one
that so.2d legitimize America's first
black president saying that he hadn't
actually been born in the US when it was
quite clear that he had this went on for
years this is this is serious lying
isn't it well the series this has been a
very very very divisive campaign and my
advice is that he's got to take steps to
rebuild the center he's right to
criticize Washington over its
partisanship an inability to forge
compromises it was right to run his
campaign he's a he's a deal maker and
let's see now if he can make some deals
in Washington he ran a racist campaign
in general Jim I'm not a partisan how
you gain is over but this wasn't a
campaign this is the man isn't it the
man ran a racist campaign how do you get
over that and work with somebody like
that eyes used like that a man who's by
seen what his actions are and let's now
watch that that's what matters we've had
divisive campaigns in the past this
country has been through some very very
difficult moments the question is what
happens now and I'm not going to get
into characterizations of the this
candidate or that candidate let's see
what President Trump does let's see who
president elect Trump picks for his
cabinet officials let's see what
policies begin to emerge that so it
doesn't shock you 60 million Americans
voted for someone who had lied
so comprehensively to them during the
campaign what is it
what's that say well let me tell you
what actually let me tell you what the
election says and that is that the
Washington elite if you will the elite
of the the coasts New York and LA have
lost touch with an awful lot of America
the so called flyover zones the
heartland and that's what came out and
voted in droves
that is what had legitimate concerns
that were tapped into by a campaign that
was very very effective 60 million
Americans don't care that they were like
like Tim we're here to talk about for
him not about this stuff but so let's
get into that and see where we go with
that
but let's look at some of the comments
that you may you wrote in May that you
were increasingly concerned about
inflammatory comments in the public
arena about Muslims and about calls for
blanket discrimination on the basis of
religion this is what you wrote as to
say Donald Trump's calls why did this
worry you so much because if you're
fighting against Islamic extremists you
have to have Muslim partners let's
remember in fact this is an existential
threat for Islamic countries this is
more of a clash within a civilization
than it is a clash between civilizations
and our successes you know I spent the
better part of a decade deployed in the
fight against Islamic extremists and
insurgents and so forth you have to have
Muslim partners to take them on and
indeed many of our successes have
featured that kind of cooperation you
called these comments toxic and
non-biodegradable
a kind of poison that once released into
our body politic is not easily expunged
well we now know that poison that
intolerance found a pretty welcome home
in America so how do you expand it that
well again this is what I talked about
earlier about now starting to forge a
new center again the center in
Washington really was diminished over
the past decade or so that's why
legislation has not been possible that's
why now
we had to have nonsensical policies such
as sequestration worth if the Congress
couldn't get together and do its job and
agree on budgets that met certain caps
that you had this alternative which is
automatic cuts it's it's an insane way
of doing business and so in fact my
first hope would be that one of the
steps that this new administration of
course let's remember now you have a
Republican in the White House and
Republicans controlling both houses of
Congress there is no excuse now that the
Republicans can offer if they are unable
to pass budgets it's not a way with with
sequestration you believe you can get to
this new center can you after a
poisonous campaign a man who said the
vote was gonna be rigged to incited
hatred of the press who had a history of
talking about seizing women's genitals
you believe you can reach a a new center
with this man that's what my advice is
again a president endorsed by the Ku
Klux Klan they're actually holding a
victory rally for him these are all
concerned Tim I wrote about this don't
get me wrong I am keenly aware of a new
you this campaign I am keenly aware of
this I am a realistic man and what I
want to see now in reality is steps
taken to reassure those who did not
support him and to bring together a
coalition this is an individual who's a
political outsider perhaps he can do
something in Washington the political
insiders he rightly criticized for being
unable to do and that is actually come
together to give a little to gain a lot
for our country this is about compromise
on Capitol Hill and together with the
White House and let's see what he can do
you you obviously are concerned about
his comments about NATO he coded
obsolete said the US allies shouldn't
benefit from US protection unless they
pay what's required of them do you share
that view and are you worried now for
the state of NATO well I'm a big
believer in coalition's I was privileged
to be a NATO commander at the forum the
answer a couple of questions here Tim
before you keep interrupting me please
but I want to get back to the question
about later okay given that Trump called
it obsolete are you worried that NATO is
not going to survive Trump's presidency
I'm not worried about that what I am
worried about is that the cooperation
and the working together that has
characterized this alliance which is so
important now given various threats
around the world that that could be
eroded now let me say by the way once
again he has been on to something that
is legitimate secretary gates in his
final session with the North Atlantic
Council I was there as the commander of
the forces in Afghanistan said to all of
them you are not paying your fair share
you're not meeting the 2% of GDP
threshold in your defense spending now
that has improved a bit in recent years
because of some of the threats that are
emerging in various places but this
coalition matters it's a cornerstone of
American security policy as a
cornerstone of the Western world's
security policy so again I'm hopeful
that the element of his comments that is
correct
that others need to do more that they
need to bear more of the burden that
they will step up to that and indeed we
can we can forge a continued cooperative
effort as we go forward and what about
the nuclear deal with Iran which he said
he'd grip up as well well I've seen
actually already clarifications of what
it is that he would intend and I have
advice there I think far more important
than tinkering with a deal that was
agreed by a multilateral group would be
to get together between the White House
and the Congress and declare a national
policy that Iran will never be allowed
to enrich uranium to weapons-grade and
then to guess what the administration
said essentially hasn't it it has not
said that there's never been a statement
of US policy that Iran will never be
allowed to enrich to what I'm talking
about Congress and the White House
together a statement of policy do you
think you can get that again we have one
party in power right now there's no
excuse for that from the Republican side
it is if they want to so again if this
if the concern is
is Iran eventually because of course the
deal indeed look the deal has some
positive elements and it has some
negative elements all of the medium
enriched uranium is out of the country
99% of the low enriched uranium the
plutonium path to the bomb is ended with
cement poured into that reactor core
there's reasonably intrusive inspections
regimes downsize it's 10 to 15 years and
it ends in Iran is reengaged in the
global economy in a way that helps them
generate much more revenue some of which
is used by nefarious elements like the
Iranian Revolutionary Guards Corps quits
force funding Hezbollah Hamas and the
murderous Bashar al Assad regime okay so
you think it's a good deal and it's
worth saying I didn't say that it's a
good deal and it's worth saving I said
that it has positive elements and it has
negative elements and I don't think that
undoing the deal is as important as
actually the White House and the
Congress working together to have a
statement of national policy that is
very clear that Iran will never be
allowed to enrich uranium to
weapons-grade and then to work with our
Gulf state partners and our ally Israel
in the region to counter the milliner
Ron Ian's activities that are ongoing
because that's the real issue okay Iran
is living up to the to the deal by and
large is a little more heavy water there
right now they'll get rid of that it's
exceeded twice yeah nice pretty modest
levels this is not something that would
cause me to lose sleep at night what is
causing concern is the continued missile
program the continued funding training
and equipping for of militia elements
that are causing considerable unrest in
various countries okay
the Obama administration leaves behind
the deal but it also leaves behind a lot
of critical issues doesn't it it leaves
behind a resurgent Russia we're seeing
increased espionage subversion cyber
warfare increasingly aggressive
maneuvers in the air and at sea a Syrian
dictator in power accused of war crimes
responsibility for the deaths of
hundreds of thousands of people and a
worsening security situation in
Afghanistan there's a large gap you left
out some other pieces I increased
China's absolutely idle their program
there's no shortage of around the world
but there's also a large gap between us
rhetoric and action isn't there and
isn't that part of the problem that's
being now exploited there is no question
that there have been statements that
weren't followed up on and that is not a
wise way of going forward the red line
that was not a red line however good the
old over chemical weapons in Syria know
no matter how good the ultimate outcome
with say 90 95 percent of those weapons
taken out but enabled by Russia Vladimir
Putin does for us what our own Congress
and the British House of Parliament was
not going to support that was very
damaging there are other issues in fact
what Trump is going to have to do again
to come back to the future rather than
the past is to navigate between what we
have seen from the US over the course of
the last 10 15 years and that is at
times over extension and then at other
times a reluctance to engage either of
those has has downsides as we have seen
and President Trump is going to have to
navigate something in the center again
you keep coming back to how can you
rebuild the Center for domestic policies
and indeed for foreign and security
policies nothing perhaps has done more
damage to to the US reputation abroad
than its military campaigns in Iraq one
of your former advisors David Kilcullen
who became chief strategist in the
office of the coordinator of
counterterrorism
big title he called the war effing
stupid and he was reprimanded by
Condoleezza Rice for it he described the
invasion as the biggest strategic
screw-up since the invasion of Russia by
Hitler in 1941 he's right isn't he I
will never offer a kind of comment on
that because as the commander of the
surge the commander of two other
elements in Iraq over the years nearly
four years I wrote more letters of
condolence to America's mothers and
fathers and any other general
officer and I am never going to get into
the comment on the policy whether we
should or should not have done that I've
certainly but hasn't that nice certain
aid I have certainly made comments about
policies within that overall policy the
firing of the military without telling
him what their future was
de-baathification without reconciliation
these created hundreds of thousands of
Iraqi citizens who had an incentive to
oppose the new Iraq rather than to
support it so I'm not hesitating to
comment on the individual policies but
I'm not going to ever offer a comment on
whether we should or should not have
done Iraq I was a soldier I executed
policies and I remain a soldier when it
comes to not commenting on that one but
you're still a human being and you don't
feel a sense of bitterness that BAPS you
were sent to war and Ally I we didn't
think we were sent to war in a lie we
believed they were chemical or nuclear
whatever weapons there there's a reason
we're wearing our chemical over garments
when we went through the berm into Iraq
from Kuwait obviously it turned out to
be wrong it was incorrect intelligence
and intelligence failure to be sure but
not a lie in 2002 the head of British
intelligence came back from Washington
and told the cabinet in London that the
the facts and the intelligence were
being fixed around the policy that's to
say the facts and the intelligence were
not true so they knew that there were no
weapons of mass distribution the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
from 95 to 97 we believed there were
weapons of mass destruction the
intelligence community did believe that
whether again you can accept it or not
but that was the belief and that was
certainly what we believed when we went
through the berm into Iraq in March of
2000 though the weapons inspectors had
said they're not their hands Blix and
his team of UN weapons is but look you
can go back and relitigate all these
different issues you asked for my view
on that
in my view let's talk about the other
factor that damaged America's reputation
and that's torture isn't it you you're
on record is saying you're firmly
against torture and you wrote the
doctrine for interrogation techniques
that were fully in line with the Geneva
Conventions you said the best way for an
interrogator to extract information is
to become a detainees best friend why
wasn't that followed by the u.s. because
of mistakes frankly mistakes Abu gorab
and some of these others these are these
are non-biodegradable to a degree they
may have a half-life but it's quite a
long one and that's why I have taken
that stand I believe from the very
beginning in Iraq when we sat down when
we realize that a number of our units
were going to have to hold detainees far
longer than we ever thought and there's
no recent war in which the u.s. held
large numbers of detainees and in the
hundred and first Airborne Division we
sat down and said you know there's only
one standard we know that's the Geneva
Convention and that's what we're going
to follow and in fact we had no issues
in the hundred and first and when I was
privileged to command later on as the
multinational force commander in Iraq
during the surge you may recall I
actually put out a memo that was titled
living our values and in it I wrote that
the enemy may do horrific things to us
but we are not going to sink to their
level we know that there are right and
left limits we visit violence upon the
enemy that is absolutely what we do but
we do it within certain norms and I
firmly believed in following those norms
and frankly the experience as well is
that and again no one was responsible
for more detainees during the surge in
Iraq we had 27,000 Iraqi detainees and
we had several thousand in Afghanistan
and our experience is that the most
accurate information from a detainee
comes indeed from a very skilled
interrogator speaking the language and
dialect understanding the the enemy's
architecture if you will and
establishing rapport with that
individual
I understand that but at the same time
torture was used in hundreds of cases by
Iraqis who were monitored by US forces
wasn't it torture of Iraqi against Iraqi
I mean one of your advised fact that's
why when I came back as a four-star
because we started seeing meat actually
now you've cut me off I'll cut you off
in fact when I came back as the
multinational force Iraq commander I
insisted that Prime Minister Maliki fire
individuals that we learned had been
involved in that indeed towards the tail
end of the time that I was doing the
train-and-equip mission okay these were
every single member of the Iraqi police
forces the three-star both two stars all
of the brigadiers
and some 60% of the battalion commanders
we insisted on replacing before I would
agree to reconstitute those units so we
were very concerned about that but it
took us a while to sort it out but one
of your advisors retired colonel James
Kaufman who worked in detention centers
that was set up with American money
torture occurred in this and the Iraqi
general matada our Samari said that he
had witnessed torture that Kaufman and
his colleague James Steele knew
everything that was going on in these
detention centers the torture the most
horrible kinds of torture did they
communicate that to you no I was no it's
not why not would you communicate that
to your boss if you were doing something
wrong but no they occupying power you
were responsible for these centers
general oversight of these centers what
they wouldn't wouldn't you well I said
no let me tell you that I did have
advisors come to me certainly and did
lay this out without question and that
is why as I said when I went back as a
floor sir I presented this first of all
this is in the tail end of my 15 and a
half month tour as a three-star and
toward the end of that time we started
getting this and so we actually finally
got documentation of this now not
involving Kaufman and steel but this is
Iraqis that had their version of black
sites if you will in Baghdad in other
places and I took that into the then
acting
Prime Minister I had a lousy and also to
the multinational force commander at the
time General George Casey and then as I
said when I came back as a four-star
what I did was took action by insisting
that all these individuals be replaced
before we would reconstitute those units
there was an enormous leverage at that
point there was a well-established
procedure wasn't there there was Frago
242 and O 3 9 which directed that Iraqi
on Iraqi abuse be reported through
operational channels and it was when I
was provided the initial report confirms
US forces were not involved in detainee
abuse no further investigation will be
conducted unless directed by h HQ
so it was an instruction to look the
other way was it not in my view no and
I'm not sure what the Frago is or if
multinational force or who it is that
issued that Frago I can tell you that
when I was the commander in Iraq as the
force mrs. suitum we took we took action
when I was the commander we took action
on this we did not permit it and we
insisted on the replacement of those who
were engaged in it in 2014
Obama said President Obama said we we
tortured some folks who came out in the
White House he said we tortured some
folks huge admission by the
commander-in-chief but where were the
prosecution's other were prosecutions as
I recall and again I you have to go to
the Department of Justice or the experts
on that kind of stuff but again all one
can do is be responsible for what when
you are the commander and when I was the
commander in Iraq overall indeed when I
was a commander's a two-star as well and
a three-star although that was a train
and equip mission and then as the
commander as a four-star in Afghanistan
we worked very very hard to ensure that
this did not take place and we took
action when it did Obama went on to add
strangely that it was important not to
feel too sanctimonious about all this
because intelligence of issues would
torture detainees we're working during a
period of extraordinary stress so is the
takeaway that if you're having a bad day
it's okay to torture people is that of
course why should why this understand
why this finesse well I I do this
against the Lord I do think it is worth
recalling context in certain cases and
the context in which some of this did
take place was a context of having had
3,000 of our citizens killed and the
most horrific terrorist attacks in US
history and a sense at that time as I
understand it also that it was a
strategic ticking time bomb scenario in
other words that there was more of this
worse of this coming and they are look i
you're preaching to the choir here and
my record as the commander in iraq as
the commander in afghanistan i think
stands up to scrutiny in this regard
given that our governments lie to us
intelligence agencies lie to us there is
a place for whistleblowers and my
question to you is given that you were
prosecuted for mishandling classified
information shouldn't there be a kinder
approach to people who have leaked
information to WikiLeaks or given
information in the public interest
shouldn't America have toned down its
criticism of people who've done that
well it depends if there was a
deliberate effort to get that out into
the public if there was damage done from
it so Snowden as Snowden cannot be
presented as he deliberately put sources
and methods of enormous value as well as
international relationships in enormous
jeopardy the public eye that is not what
I that's not actually well I think
you're taking this out of context
because holder also says that he holders
not pull punches about the damage that
was done holders I think but again you
can ask Holder again I'm my view is that
he in in hugely egregious ways look what
I did was share something that was never
revealed it was to get dates not further
all the other stuff in there it was a
mistake I acknowledged it I
paid my dues for that there's leakers
all the time if there's damaging leaks
we pursued those and indeed you should
there's wouldn't need them if
government's told the truth though would
we do it well again there are certain
things that it is okay not to say I'm
not saying that government lied about
what our intelligence agencies were
doing but they were not going to tell
the enemy that we were had certain
capabilities that enabled us to monitor
various of their communications means or
that kind of stuff
good to have you on cope its own general
thank you you bet thank you
you